le gouvernement va venir en aide au
Resto du Coeur 15 millions d'euros
d'aide supplémentaires à l'association
en difficulté les restos font face à
l'inflation et à l'augmentation de la
précarité ils ont déjà aidé 1,3 millions
de personnes en 2023 alors que l'année
n'est pas terminée contre 1,1 million en
2022 le président de l'association a
annoncé qu'il allait devoir restreindre
le nombre de bénéficiaires au mois de
novembre moi je pense que Coluche doit
se retourner dans sa tombe quoi parce
que Coluche il a créé les Restos du
Coeur pour pallier au manquement de
l'État parce que c'était ça quand même
l'idée c'est qu'il y avait quelques
millions de pauvres en France et pour
donner à bouffer à quelques millions de
pauvres plutôt que d'aller sauver toute
la planète Coluche il crée des Restos du
Coeur l'État a tellement rien fait
depuis ce jour-là que l'État en est
aujourd'hui a voté des subventions pour
que les Restos du Coeur vivent non mais
tu te rends compte le truc où on en est
quoi avec d'un côté des bénéficiaires de
plus en plus nombreux et de l'autre des
coups de fonctionnement qui explosent
les rest le coeur n'arrive plus à s'en
sortir l'association pourrait devoir
fermer d'ici trois ans et les 15
millions d'euros promis hier par le
gouvernement ne seront pas suffisants
sur ces 15 millions il y en avait déjà
10 qui étaient dans le tuyau donc la
vraie augmentation c'est 5 millions et
puis c'est très en deçà c'est une bonne
chose ça va dans le bon sens mais il
faudra beaucoup plus 10 millions c'est
notre chiffre du jour et c'est le
sérieux coup de pouce de Bernard Arnault
au resto du coeur le propriétaire du
numéro 1 mondial du luxe LVMH va verser
10 millions d'euros à l'association en
difficulté hier l'État s'est engagé sur
une aide supplémentaire de 15 millions
d'euros les restos font face à la fois
l'inflation et à l'augmentation du
nombre de précaires qui ont recours
assez services
voilà
merci merci beaucoup
à l'élégance
toi avec ton t-shirt bien rayé avec des
grosses rayures c'est pas sur table
[Musique]
boum le choc Grég arrive bon je suis pas
très rassurée
parce que dans une interview récente
j'avais dit qu'il était pas très
intelligent donc là j'ai un peu une
appréhension je me dis voilà il va me
rentrer dedans c'est sûr il faut dire
bonjour maintenant c'est ça couleur
dites quoi à vos fans merci
simplement mes femmes c'était français
avec qui on a partagé des souvenirs des
femmes comme si il n'avait pas de
cerveau quels sont vos passions
j'aime les gens en fait moi profondément
ah c'est joli ça
partage maintenant que smartphone et
j'aime que on se parle qu'on discute
avec 83 ans à l'intérieur 38
mais j'adore le rire
sauf que 5 minutes plus tard
la découverte de marjolaine première
grande surprise moi je vais faire la
bise comme ça
je m'attendais à tous le fait de voir
que Greg vienne me faire la bise et que
c'est tout à fait amical ça me rassure
mais par contre je trouve que Grega
vieille
je suis prêt à tout donner je suis par
amour je suis capable de faire beaucoup
de choses et en plus de faire grandir la
personne de l'aider
pas choisi pour tes pieds toi mais non
pas là c'est quoi ah oui j'ai vu c'est
ça que tu dis juste pour ça tu me
fais peur
ça part ça a l'air de partir je te jure
il va mériter une journée spéciale papa
l'annonce de l'heureuse nouvelle a viré
au drame au Mexique ses futurs parents
organiser une gender evil party une fête
où l'on révèle le sexe du bébé avec du
rose ou du bleu ici était utilisé un
avion qui lâche de la fumée c'est normal
qu'il perd une aile beaucoup moins
l'appareil s'est ensuite écrasé et le
pilote est décédé on ne connaît pas les
causes de l'accident mais beaucoup
d'internautes s'étonnent du comportement
des personnes présentes d'autres
dénoncent une surenchère lors de ses
événements véritable phénomène sur les
réseaux sociaux conseil municipal d'une
ville japonaise oh non Michy je vous
explique ils ont eu la bonne idée
d'envoyer à tous les foyers comprenant
des femmes enceintes des petits flyers
pour expliquer aux dames comment se
comporter avec ces messieurs pendant la
grossesse avec des injonctions pour
qu'elle fasse des efforts pour moins
énerver les messieurs pour moins de nous
prendre la tête à leur mari donc pendant
cette période exemple apprenez à vous
contenir vous allez être irrité pour des
raisons inconnues sans doute les
hormones ce n'est pas monsieur d'en
payer les pots cassés écrivent-ils c'est
bon
[Musique]
si vous prenez 4 douches par jour ça
peut être sympa c'est du temps ensemble
un touriste allemand porte plainte
contre son voyageiste pour
insatisfaction sexuelle
un satisfaction sexuelle voilà le motif
de la plante d'un touriste à l'encontre
de son voyage East une plainte étayée
par le touriste allemand car l'homme
était déçu de la literie de l'hôtel ce
que dénon cet homme et qu'il avait
demandé un lit double et que sa chambre
comportait de lit simple rapprochés ce
qui a provoqué son insatisfaction
sexuelle j'ai tout fait pour qu'elle
soit le mieux possible qu'elle se sente
chez elle quoi sauf peut-être de mettre
le bon t-shirt
a duré indéterminé ouais c'est vrai que
ça dénote
faites face à chez vous
[Musique]
ça devrait passer en heures creuse ça
purée moins de 10000 téléspectateurs
pour l'avocat de l'hôtel c'est clair le
problème ne vient pas de la literie le
problème ne venait ni des Baléares ni de
l'hôtel il venait probablement du manque
d'imagination du citoyen allemand c'est
touriste allemand devra donc trouver
d'autres excuses pour justifier ses
piètres prestations sexuelles
on boit pas un coup